foreign
the summer of 2020 I had just
gotten my house already for sale
spending a lot of money uh fixing it up
I'd spent probably 20
000 then getting it uh ready for sale
and then sold it it was under contract
for one week a day that this happened
[Music]
I guess he knew that I was living in
Montana most of the time he must have
seen the for sale sign on the house
he showed up at uh my house with this
young 15 year old girl that he was on
the run with
[Music]
our neighbors had called me and showed
me a little clip
you know what was going on and they were
recording all the
it was like 30 tear gas canisters
gone in through the roof gone in through
six Windows the girl had come out they
said it about three hours before that
she told them that he had a backpack
with guns in it and so the police had to
be cautious I understand that though he
never fired at them that I am aware of
they put a bomb on the
um garage door
and blew that off they used a Humvee to
run down my back fence
and what I was told is the reason they
did a lot of that
was to
bring about confusion
you know to the perpetrator inside and
they call it shock and awe so while they
were doing all of this damage to my
house
he apparently
killed himself
tear gas unfortunately got my daughter's
Little Chihuahua
and we ended up having to put him to
sleep
the HazMat team threw everything out
they had two huge containers uh in front
of my house and both were filled to the
full I mean couches chairs
dishes everything went everything that
you have in the house I remember
a calling my insurance company and
thinking that everything was going to be
covered
[Music]
she said we don't pay those claims and I
said you don't understand
I'm trying to tell her you don't
understand and she's telling me you
don't understand we've never paid a
claim like this and I said I want to
talk to your insurance company please
and she said fine
you know but you won't get a dime those
were her exact words
I laid on my couch here
for
probably a couple of days just crying I
mean I could barely do anything because
now my house was no longer sold I
couldn't pay off this property I was
forced into
um
semi-retime mostly retirement when the
cancer came because I could no longer
call on patients
my name is Jeff Redfern and I'm an
attorney at The Institute for justice
the government has this power called
eminent domain which means you know most
familiar use of it would be like taking
your house for a road they can take your
property if they need to for a public
use but they have to pay you just
compensation and that's in the Fifth
Amendment so we argued that the
destruction of Vicki Baker's house in
order to take a dangerous criminal off
the street was it taking just like it
would be a taking if they took your
house to build a road or if your house
were destroyed because they built a dam
and your land got flooded or any number
of other ways that that government can
intentionally destroy private property
sometimes for very good reasons
it's it's a very good thing that the
police got this guy off the street and
and nobody's disputing that
it's just about you know who has to bear
the cost of that you know the answer to
that can't be well Vicki Baker uh you
know a cancer survivor retiree
um has to Bear over sixty thousand
dollars in order to pay for something
that the town could pay for if it chose
to
[Music]
I felt Vindicated I felt okay somebody
understands somebody else doesn't want
this to happen to anybody else and they
knew by giving me a win that it might
help other individuals
[Music]
I feel we will win this thing because I
feel it is right
feel God is on our side
[Music]